hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren da ihr vor eineinhalb Wochen bei
meiner letzten hilf miraction hier auf
meinem Youtube Kanal im Durchschnitt so
passiert das 20.000 die Hirnzellen
verloren hab dachte ich mir reagieren
wir heute doch mal gemeinsam auf Fame um
jeden Preis mein Kind muss berühmt
werden und wie das gang und gäbe ist
schauen wir uns natürlich vorher erstmal
die Kommentare an das Mädchen
Schauspieler besser als alle bisherigen
Schauspieler bei hilf mir zusammen
wetten die Ohrringe sind größer als das
Gehirn der Mutter hätte sie das Geld für
die Tanzstunde lieber ein
Abschminktücher investiert sieht ja
schlimm aus die Mascara immer dasselbe
Story brauchen Geld fragen jemand nach
Geld klauen bekommen Stress mit
Verwandten und Freunden benutze diesen
Kommentar als Grinch Button die Mutter
hatte ihr Gehirn wohl im Solarium
vergessen ich liebe diese authentische
Schauspielerei welche Eltern lassen ihre
Kinder bei hilf mir mitspielen oh Mann
jede Folge wird besser und besser und
damit starten wir auch direkt rein
jasmin ist mit ihrer sechsjährigen
Tochter beim Tanztraining okay
Privatstunden für 320 € im Monat okay
nichts ist zu teuer für die junge Mutter
sie will aus ihrer Tochter Mia beim
großen Star machen okay um jeden Preis
zwei Stunden bei mir und ist ein
richtiges Naturtalent ganz toll
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Hip Hop
Hip Hop aha
und zwar die Rate für diesen Monat ist
noch offen ja tut mir leid gelaufen sein
mit der Überweisung aber ich komme mich
gleich direkt rum ja das ist wichtig
weil sie wissen dass seine renommierte
Schule und gedulden also keine offenen
Zahlungen und ja ich musste eigentlich
falsch gelaufen
denkt sie die ist eine Blume aber eine
Blume hat sie ja eh schon in den Haaren
also jetzt verstehe ich auch was mit den
Ohrringen gemeint
und zwar wollte ich mit dir über die
Ballettstunden von mir reden die noch
bezahlt werden müssen
320 Euro für die Tanzschule
diese Effekte sind Wahnsinn ne da musst
du dir einen Nebenjob suchen und auch
Geld dazu verdienen
Job suchen ich muss doch mit dem Kind
auch zu den tanzen hingehen und
für Sie da sein
hat gar keinen Job
also ihr Job ist einfach nur mit ihrem
Kind zu den Tanzstunden hinzugehen
Jasmin versucht ihre verlorenen Träume
durch ihr Kind zu verwirklichen das ist
total gefährlich sie ignoriert die
Bedürfnisse Ihres eigenen Kindes das ist
sehr gut formuliert
aber auch da frage ich mich warum sie
ein Oberteil mit Delfinen an hat
ist das denn die Mutter
geht um dein Enkelin es ist die Mutter
die wollte fragen ob du vielleicht 400 €
leihen könntest
ich war noch nicht so ganz verstehe
warum dieses kleine Kind dachte dass sie
Hip Hop tanzt weil Ballett und Hip Hop
haben so viel am Hut wie Spaghetti und
Pizza wohl das eigentlich relativ viel
miteinander hat ja richtig ja genau
finde ich wo geht's genau
nach die fahren in die Berge oder so die
Berge ich finde die kleine die soll ja
auch eine schöne Klassenfahrt haben ne
ich weiß das ja damals da freut man sich
so drauf und wenn man dann als Frau das
finde ich ja so schrecklich wenn so ein
Bett sowas ne
braunes Ding hinten dran habe ich mir
mal den kompletten Kinn aufgestoßen
musste genäht werden
100 Prozent ich lege jetzt schon meine
Hand dafür ins Feuer das hier die Jasmin
irgendwann später da reinkommt dann mit
so einer spuki Musik die Mutter ist
nicht zu Hause was wird Jasmin jetzt tun
und dann greift die zwischen die
Matratze und Geld Hallo sehe wir
veranstalten ein ganz großes Casting und
suchen Tänzer für eine Werbeagentur
lassen Alter ist doch eventuell was für
sie oh Jo Jo Jo Jo Jo Jo
ich finde es aber generell ganz
schwierig wenn sich Eltern so messen
über ihre Kinder
so ja das ähm ja also legt halt Wert auf
ganz besondere Turnschuhe und wenn man
sich die erwirbt dann spült man er spürt
man sich Bonuspunkte damit
das heißt der Ballett Talent Scout achte
nicht darauf wie die Mädels tanzen
sondern was sie für Schuhe anhaben
menschlich gesehen geil einfach geil was
ist eigentlich ein Casting warum darf
sie eigentlich Cola trinken am
hellichten Tag
das durfte ich nie
ich durfte einmal im Monat Cola trinken
was ist das hier eigentlich für ein Deko
wackeln
du alles wackeln
ey die mia ist vielleicht fünf oder so
soll die jetzt irgendwie twerkerin
werden oder oder was die 23-Jährige muss
dringend eine Lösung finden
ja doch selfie Kinder mit 17 bekommen
oder so
Sparkasse ah nein was nein sagt nicht
die Stadt war Köln
ist nichts zu teuer Jasmin greift zu und
fällt die Unterschrift ihres Freundes
[Musik]
Kündigung
was kündigen die denn das geht
die tun hier einfach so als würde diese
Szene gerade hinter dem stattfinden die
sind voll im Greenscreen das Casting von
mir steht kurz bevor jasmin hat ihre
Spieluhr für 130 € bei einem Pfandleiher
verkaufen können ach du Kacke damit kann
sie auf jeden Fall die DVD für ihre
Tochter kaufen doch es fehlen immer noch
70 € für die Klassenfahrt ach die
Spannung stark es gibt wirklich eine
Klassenfahrt
ich dachte das hätte die sich ausgedacht
[Musik]
tanzen oder her aber warum hat er denn
eine wischmop-frisur
100%ig ja auf jeden Fall wir zeichnen
grundsätzlich jedes Casting auf okay
weil das ist wirklich sehr wichtig dass
wir die DVD kaufen können das ist ein
großer Augenblick für uns ne für uns
merkst du schon
für uns ja wir haben uns dann für einen
entschieden die gegen die Siegerin von
den anderen Tanzschulen antreten wird in
einem weiteren Casting und ich glaube
wir können sagen das ist die mehrere
nein okay mir hat gewonnen aber
es gibt noch ein weiteres Casting gegen
andere Tanzschuhe
gut ich gehe jetzt noch gerade
denken Sie die ist ein Audi oder was wo
findet das zweite Casting ist statt das
ist in Holland direkt am Meer in Holland
plötzlich nach Holland und nicht mehr in
die Berge jasmin ist bereits alles
durchgegangen er steht das Wasser bis
zum Hals es gibt ja noch eine Matratze
ne
ich zeige euch die Matratze wird noch
geplündert sie sieht nur noch eine
Lösung um an das Geld für die
Hollandreise und die Klassenfahrt zu
kommen die Matratze Laptop was
Paddy slapt jetzt die hat doch schon das
Sparbuch von Paddy gefällt schon
gekündigt oder irgendwas gemacht jetzt
will ich auch nicht den Laptop von ihm
verkaufen bereits zwei Stunden später
hat Jasmin das Laptop für 310 € an ein
Elektro Gebrauchtwagen verkauft ach du
Kacke davon kann sie auf jeden Fall die
Reise nach Holland bezahlen lassen dann
noch 90 €. was witzig werden
Happy End hätte wenn mir jetzt das
zweite Casting gewinnen und dann
bekommen die einfach so 5 Millionen Euro
Twist hier sieht man deutlich Jasmin
projiziert ihre Erwartungen und Wünsche
auf mir ja das hat jeder gesehen mit
zwei Augen ne sie ignoriert die Signale
ihre Tochter die eigentlich was ganz
anderes bin das was
was ist mit Holland was ist mit dem
Laptop was ist mit der Matratze von der
Mutter was ist mit dem komischen
Wischmop Casting Tüten
[Musik]